الصحافه الاسبانيه تهاجمون لاعبي لاروخا
رونالدو يغيب عن التدريبات مجددا وبكم
يزور معسكر الاسود الثلاثه هذه الخبر
وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه رياضه اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
لن ترحم الصحافه الاسبانيه اللاعبين منتخب
الاروخا بعد خروجه من مبكر ماركه كاس
العالم الان هي اكبر من اسبانيا بينما
كتبت البايس استحواذا على الكره دون فائده
من جهتها
الاولى وكتبت الضربه القاضيه في المونديال
وبعد فوز البرتغال الكبير امام سويسرا
ومشاركه رونالدو كبديل رفض دون خوض
التدريبات الجماعيه اليوم لمنتخب واكتفى
بالتدرب داخل الصاله الرياضيه بحجه انه لا
يتدرب مع الفريق الاحتياطي وهذا بحسب
تقرير اعلاميه وجره العاده لن يتدرب
الفريق الاحتياطي هداه المباراه مع خوض
اللاعبين الاساسيين تدريبات المستشفائيه
وقبل انهاء المبكر الذي سيجمع منتخب
انجلترا امام فرنسا حامله النقب زار نجم
ديفيد بيكم معسكر الاسود الثلاثه لدعم
اللاعبين قبل المواجهه الحاسمه لكن الطريق
خاصه مع النجم الذي يعتبره الاعلى
وفي خبرنا الاخير نشر نجم ارسنال والمنتخب
البرازيلي قبل يجوز صوره له بعد العمليه
الجراحيه التي خاضها لها بعد اصابه في
الركبه تعرض لها في دور المجموعات الجزء
شارك متابعيه عبر حسابي على الانستقرام
صوره له بعد العمليه الجراحيه التي
ستبعدها عن باقي منافسه المونديال وعن بعض
مباريات نادي ارسنال الذي وضعها خطه
علاجيه للاعب في الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]